how's it going bros my name is
p welcome to my own game I didn't make
this it was made by
Kwing uh it's on new grounds I it wasn't
even he who sent it to me I'm really
surprised when I saw it and it's not a
scary game it's just I don't know it's
kind of random it's called PewDiePie
Space Invaders uh it's pretty much Space
Invaders but uh I don't know PewDiePie
uh you move AR kees fire with the space
bar hit a bro or a barrel for one point
hit the untrusted statues for 10 points
hit the enemies accurate to build up a
shank one bullets fired by PewDiePie can
break a Shane only I can break Shane you
guys can break anyway I'll leave a down
I mean a link in the description by the
way if you want bro want to play it's
actually really addicting build a higher
chain to build Piggy saano and Sho all
right here we
go all right and that I don't even know
what that alien thing is up there but
we're going to start by killing the Bros
in the barrels oh yeah oh we got Stefano
iOS I am
Stefano oh we lost Stefano no I need
the uh anyway I think I don't know if
you understood it right let's get that
thing yes I don't trust you let's get
again all
right oh we got shano I L I am
stfo oh piggy y hey what's up my name is
share mode
yes oh no I think you get double points
if you are in share mode I don't really
share mode activated oh no oh nice nice
nice we got
shano my
pig oh this game is awesome so anyway I
thought maybe I could chair activate it
I could try this for as long as
I um I don't know dieing then you can
leave a video oh no I lost my Sheron God
damn it I don't trust
you um and if you bothos get any higher
high score than me you can leave a video
response showing it to me cuz I don't
just yet I'm just kidding I trust you
the battles remind me of like Donkey
Kong or something oh no my broke my
shank ah Focus pity all right I'm just
going to finish these
office I don't T you let's do this
quicker oh SPO
damn I'm good damn I'm good I'm damn
fine CH yes chair mode
activated I don't trust this game I
don't know why i' I've been playing this
game for a while it's no my Shane I
think my high score is like th000 or
something I must beat a th000 it's going
to take forever and this game isn't
really changing it's a very simple game
I don't know I just feel like it's
awesome everything you bros do for me
and I feel like the least I can do
is I don't put it on YouTube I
guess oh man oh bro oh bro why are you
so
sexy he's using the animated bro but
it's not really animated come on oh no
come on let's get the shame
going
mhm I love how I shoot laser beam by the
way it's obvious cuz I'm PewDiePie and
actual
Las
uh since nothing really is going on I
guess you can tell the reason behind my
name a lot of people have been asking
for it it's because um I don't know I I
think I saw it somewhere honestly I
don't mean I just like I saw the nicking
pewy and I started screaming out
randomly like when I was playing video
games I guess and people thought it was
fun I used to go to this net cafe a lot
and uh the guy who owned it I remember
every time I entered he was like back I
don't know was really funny so I think
that's why I kept it I had a lot of
names in my past a lot of names but I
don't know I've been making pey for like
I don't know forever I'm sicking with P
I think I come on share mode oh no I
lost share
mode all right anyway I realized it's is
not really interesting to watch too long
but anyway I'm going to leave the link
download link in the description if if
you both want to try it out uh anyway
that's pretty much
it
[Music]
wa I just came from there it's
impossible why am I talking like Stan oh
c I don't like
COG